it's true that economics is often called
the dismal science and it makes you feel
cold and almost like a bean counter if
you're just saying well how much money
does that cost and how much good does
that do but of course the alternative
not thinking about how much good do you
do for every dollar doesn't make the
constraint we only have a limited amount
of money to do good go away but it
certainly means that we end up leaving
this world less good than what it could
otherwise have been so while I
understand the emotion we also want to
feel good we also want to make sure that
we have done good the ultimate arbiter
of that will have to be well how much
money did we spend and how well did we
spend it so I think it can inform our
choices and hopefully make it possible
for us to make sure that we didn't just
feel good that we didn't just feel like
oh this is really cool but that we
actually left this world a better world
because fundamentally I don't think our
kids and grandkids are going to feel
great about what we did simply because
we had great speeches or felt very good
about ourselves but ultimately they're
going to judge us and how well we did
if you look through a human civilization
we've had lots of problems that seemed
insurmountable at the time but we've
overcome them because we're quite
innovative species so my biggest fear is
not that we are not going to do much
better in the future my biggest fear is
that we're not going to do as well as we
possibly could we have lots of solution
we have in metz cost-effective solutions
let's pick those and let's not just make
simple politically correct but
ultimately feeble ways to tackle the
future but let's make the effective ones
looking at 50 years ahead is always
fraught with difficulty but if we look
at the only scenarios have actually been
made from the UN climate panel they
indicate that will have a whirl there'll
be much richer and likewise the world
health organization in the world food
organization tells of a world there'll
be much healthier live much longer and
quite likely will be much better fed so
fundamentally it's going to be a world
that will be much better whether it be a
little more better or a little less
better is the choices that we really
have to decide and I hope that we're
going to make good choices but I fear
that we're just going to make the
choices make us feel good but won't
actually affect very much into the
future what businesses can do would they
can hope to steer this conversation not
by picking the easy and simple and
politically correct solutions themselves
but by insisting in the public discourse
that this has to be about what is
effective not just what makes us feel
good